What it do blood? Welcome to Thug
Notes, yo main hookup for classical literature
summary and analysis. This week we keepin it real with
Crime and Punishment by Fyodor Dostoevsky
Now C&P is the story of one of the
baddest white boys in western literature,
mah boy Roskalnikov, or “Rodya,” as he
like to be called.
One day he rolls up to the house of some ol’
crusty pawnbroker hag to slang some of his
bling for that rent money. After this ho does
my boy straight dirty, he goes to the local
pub where he overhears some other hustlas
talkin mess about this old hag.
Man it sure would be cold and righteous if some
badass mutha just went up and glocked that
bitch. Do society a favor, and give her money
to the po’. Naw mean?
So Rodya steps up. Grabs his self
an axe. Rolls up to the pawnbroker’s crib
and BAM, he straight mercs that bitch like
a cold blooded gangsta. Just when he bout
to bounce, her sister rolls in. Now my honky
be knowin you can’t be leavin no witnesses.
Pop! Pop! That bitch goes down and Rodya bails
before the po-lice arrive.
Days pass and mah boy Rodya tries
to shake the funk of murdering someone. News
comes that a detective by the name of Porfiry
Petrovich wanna holla at our boy. Oh snap!
Porfiry Petrovich lays down the gauntlet
and says “Rodya, stop frontin, I know it
was you that killed these bitches.” But Rodya doesn't fall for that trap. He shakes off that playa hata.
Still tortured by that whack ass deed,
Rodya seeks solace in the arms of some nasty trick named Sonya.
Sonya gets all crunk and tells him
that he gotta turn his self in to the po-po
in order for God to forgive him.
So Rodya goes to the middle of the
market and kisses the ground to beg God for
forgiveness. Then he confesses to Porfiry
and is pinched by the 5-O. Only the hard labor
of prison life in Siberia can give our boy
Rodya salvation.
Now if yo bitch ass be paying
attention, you mighta noticed that Rodya’s
article sounds a lot like Nietzche’s
writings on the Ubermensch
You might even say that Dostoevsky’s
conclusion that one must embrace suffering
to achieve redemption is
a big “fu** you” to Nietzche’s postmodern
nihilism. Ya hear me?
Peep this motif, son: the recurring
disjoint between contemplation and experience.
At first, My dawg Rodya thinks he knows what’s
up just cuz it sound all good and righteous
in his head. some
For example,
homeboy think he can ghost a bitch and not
trip. But, on the real, actually killin a
bitch is too much for this pimpjuice to bear.
Yo this is real talk right here:
the Christian symbolism is underlined by the
pagan symbols of the earth. When dat ho Sonya
tells Rodya to confess, she tells him to kiss
the ground- acknowledging the earth as the
baby mama of all men. It’s like this stunna
is making the transition from a cold, hard
ass rationalist in to an red blooded human
being. Ya heard?
You also best be lookin out for
Dostoevsky’s use of duality up in this heezy.
First off, Roskalnikov’s name straight up
means “schism,” which in basic english
means divide. Now what means is that my boy
Rodya be playin both sides of the court whole
bunch of ways: sensibility
and intelligence, self-sacrifice and self
assertion, God-man and man-God, good and evil.
I could go on, playa!
Look, If you ain’t read this sh**,
you need to get yo ass to the public library and get
yoself a copy.
Thanks for tuning in to Thug Notes, blood,
See yo ass next week.